today's inflation read blowing up the
notion that inflation has peaked the
question now is when will it and as long
as it remains hot where can you find
Opportunities with us now as pomp
Investments founder Anthony pompliano
better known to many of you as Pop
Welcome to our new program it's good to
see you on this venue
good to see you Scott how are you I'm
good thanks you know your tweets today
caught my attention first and foremost
and obviously I want to discuss crypto
and Bitcoin with you during this this
interview but let's start with these
tweets you had undisciplined monetary
and fiscal policy doesn't work uh was
one of them you can't print trillions of
dollars and manipulate markets without
consequences were you surprised by the
CPI print as much as others
this is Scott if you go back to January
1st 2020 and you look at asset prices
since then uh Bitcoin is up 400 percent
since that point the s p is up about 22
nasdaq's up 36 Gold's up about 10. the
dollar is basically falling off a cliff
median home prices are up 30 percent and
I think what we're watching is that
undisciplined monetary and fiscal policy
let's turn the stock market another
asset uh into a casino it's created
incredible short-term thinking among
investors but over the long run there is
one thing that continues to act exactly
as it's designed which is Bitcoin and
the people who have continued to dollar
cost average into that asset 65.5 of all
Bitcoin hasn't moved in a year
regardless of the volatility and it
continues to serve as the one thing that
no one can manipulate and no one can
change that programmatic monetary policy
and in light of the undisciplined
monetary and fiscal policy it tends to
be the sanity in an insane world
so there's a lot in there of what of
what obviously you you just said and
you've maintained for a long time
certainly as long as I can remember that
Bitcoin uh is an inflation hedge you you
tweet it I'm looking at one from August
of 2021 uh where you cite the return
over the last 12 months of gold versus
Bitcoin and you say quote Bitcoin is the
true inflation hedge if that is the case
why has Bitcoin been cut in half and why
doesn't it go up if the inflation read
was so hot
yeah I think there's two things that are
important to understand first assets
that are inflation Hedges they move
before the inflation comes so if you
remember in 2020 Paul Tudor Jones
Stanley drucken Miller many other
sophisticated investors came out and
said listen I think inflation is coming
and I am going to move my Assets Now in
anticipation and that's where you saw
Bitcoin go from about ten thousand
dollars all the way up to sixty four
thousand dollars in March of 2021. we
started to get the over five percent
inflation uh prints in June July of the
summer of 2021 and so inflation hedge
assets moved before now that's why if
you go back from before the pandemic to
today Bitcoin being up 400 percent I
always say to people if you can go back
and Rewind time with the benefit of
hindsight you wouldn't buy stocks you
wouldn't buy bonds you wouldn't buy real
estate you would have bought Bitcoin it
has been the best performer and it has
served as that inflation hedge now the
second thing to understand also is that
right now we're in this slow bleed of
some sort of liquidity crisis if you go
back to 2008 2009 there was a little
liquidity crisis over the summer of 08
and gold went down 30 percent the
government stepped in with tons of
stimulus and gold over the next two
years rallied and hit an all-time high
my thesis in 2020 was exactly that on
March 12th I wrote and I said we're in a
liquidity crisis uh and the government's
going to have to step in when they step
in people will run towards these Safe
Haven assets that have sound money
principles Bitcoin is digital sound
money and so right now in 2022 what
we're watching is that Bitcoin is going
down and correlations are going towards
one across all assets so bitcoin's going
down but so are stocks bonds real estate
Etc and the fed's in control and they're
in their crashing asset prices but what
ends up occurring is that once we get
out of these higher correlation periods
Bitcoin will continue to outperform over
a long period of time and the reason is
you have a finite asset that simply has
a programmatic monetary pulse humans are
horrible at predicting the future and so
if you go and you look at the
macroeconomic issues that we've faced
right now wolves inequality has never
been worse in America and the reason is
because 45 of Americans have no
investable assets they are getting
punished by this High inflation prices
at home is 12 percent